[Applause]
you are so sweet thank you happy Monday
everyone and hello
Cala so we heard a lot about the wall
when Trump was in office but there's
another wall when it comes to the Border
issue the one between reality and what
the media will port and it's a wall 50
times harder to breach than the one
Trump was building but finally it looks
like that wall is crumbling like a
wicker chair under Anna
Navaro we've all seen the video of a
dozen migrants attacking two cops in
Times Square the video seems to have
broken through the media moat that
protects the left and shown everyone
what Progressive policies on immigration
really look like and it's scarier than
Jesse Waters without his hair and
makeup yeah for those who support law
enforcement the images have become like
the famous Rodney King video but in
reverse and it's hard for us to all just
get along when we see the people we gave
food shelter and cash then beat up our
protectors and now the media and DS act
like they suddenly care J I wonder if it
has anything to do with this whole
election year thingy I guess you can't
turn the country blue when you're
turning it citizens black and blue and
so here in New York progressives are
sweating like AOC trying to make change
for a
quarter Take Manhattan da Alvin Bragg
another Soros hand puppet it was Bragg
who decided not to even ask for bail for
the attackers who predictably fled New
York upon their release it's the biggest
mess Al's made since someone handed him
a sloppy joe in a vibrating
chair Last Week Big Al gave a hasty
press conference trying to clean up his
latest mess in Manhattan we do not
tolerate or accept assaults on police
officers I watched the tape this week uh
despicable Behavior it sickened me and
outraged me sickened and outraged but
not enough to do anything about it the
incompetent boob now this is the same
brag who said in his first day in office
that the office will seek dispositions
that avoid immigration consequences that
that was the cause and now this is the
effect cause and effect Al just like
those cronuts are turning your waistline
into the
equator is it me or is declaring on day
one that illegals have a get out of jail
free card not exactly a recipe for a
successful prosecutor and yet they can't
stop creating more incentives take New
York City's new $53 million program to
give prepaid credit cards to migrant
families literal free money handed out
to so-called called Asylum Seekers
apparently the pre-loaded cards are only
good at grocery stores and migrants must
sign an affidavit swearing they only
spended on food and baby supplies yeah
and they also promis to ease up on the
assault then there's New York mayor Eric
Adams who wrote into office on the
promise of restoring Law and Order one
vegan school lunch at a time Adams could
resend the city's Sanctuary status
thereby allowing cops to cooperate with
ice you remember ice who the Dems deemed
the worst villain on Earth for doing the
job the Dems now so desperately need to
be done but Adams who previously said
the migrant crisis would destroy New
York gee thanks Miss Cleo has apparently
vanished into witness protection could
it be that visit he got from the FBI who
took his phones and announced they
investigating him I guess nothing brings
on an appreciation of Biden's policy
Genius Like A looming Federal indictment
speaking of migration there's New York
Governor Kathy h
whose use of a turkey baster to inject
Botox has her eyebrows migrating to
Canada in the wake of the video outrage
hok is now saying that deportation is
quote worth checking
into yeah that's just what New York
needs a bold leader who's not afraid to
eventually look into things but only
after two PM tee tissue
massage this by the way is the same hok
who has not only a bedded the criminal
justice reforms that allowed the
migrants release but signed a law that
makes it a crime to even threaten to get
someone deported it's the only thing
that keeps me from getting cat sent back
to
Detroit hok could also resend the
executive order that bans New York State
officials from cooperating with ice and
she could fire Alvin Bragg for little
things like not doing his job but
that'll be a cold day in hell maybe
that's why her face is frozen
finally there's Joe let's forget the
roughly 90 Trump era border border
initiatives he revoked when taking
office we know Joe certainly has he
forgets to remove his suit before
entering his walk-in
shower right now without Congress Biden
could sign an executive order that
brings back remain in Mexico the
simplest most effective Southern border
policy we we've had or he could invoke
this measure right from his Government
website and refer specifically to the
vene vuelan migrants quote DHS may also
decide to terminate your parole at its
discretion for other reasons such as
violating any laws of the US if you stay
in the US after your parole expires
officials who encounter you may refer
you to ice for immigration proceedings
in other words Joe Biden at his
discretion could simply order these
defendants ejected like a grandchild at
a Biden family
reunion I
know
but he won't because Venezuela won't
take him back and anything that
resembles Common Sense makes him agree
with the big evil orange meanie on top
of this huge groups of illegals from
China were recently seen pouring into
the southern border on 60 Minutes a
steady stream right through a gap in the
fence who could have seen that
coming and so now Senate Dems are
cooperating with Republic on an
immigration deal it even includes
building that immoral wall we keep
hearing so much about sure they want to
make it out of papermache and cotton
candy but at least it's a start suddenly
the Dems sound a lot like you know who
it's that same old Democrat specialty
push a policy that feels good but does
bad then when it causes predictable
chaos turn into Republicans to try to
clean it up rinse and repeat they chaos
junkies addicted to dumb Joe Chuck and
Nancy how about a dose of common sense
for once and when the country really
needs it not when you're scared of being
throwing out on your
asses let's
welcome tonight's
guest he's smart funny and Charming but
enough about the guest who dropped out
here's Fox News contributor Tom
shaloo her commentary gives liberals
dissenter editorinchief of the
Federalist Molly
Hemingway he recently graced the cover
of white hobo Magazine TV writer and
producer Rob
log and terrorists put her on their
watch list New York Times bestselling
author and Fox News contributor cat
to Tom always a pleasure having you on
the program yeah yeah there you go very
cheery monologue Greg I know I know but
it's amazing that this guy says he
couldn't arrest those people because he
wasn't sure who they were why not just
take them all in they're a gang and then
figure it out yeah and I mean the mayor
now they're giving the free money which
is probably better spent if you hand it
directly to them than handing it to
these non-governmental organizations and
everybody else the amount of waste you
can see just walking from here over to
Grand Central they have migrants coming
out of the hotels right now right uh and
then this border bill which you got
Republicans that are preaching to me I
mean uh what's his name uh Dan crenchaw
yeah he's Dan splaining me oh you got to
read the bill you got to read the bill
oh it's in the details I'm not going to
read the bill no I don't trust the bill
there's already laws on the border who
needs another bill it's already against
the law to come into our country and
they're not enforcing that so I don't
need somebody explaining that to me uh
and have looked at the bill 5,000 people
a day that's like if you want to stop
shoplifting MH and then you're like okay
let's build a shipping and receiving
dock just for the shoplifters and they
can steal 5,000 a day and after that
we're going to shut down the shipping
and receiving and say you got to go
around the front and you got to steal
the oldfashioned way you know that is a
great
analogy it is it is but the problem with
this bill is I'm not even sure what
you're saying is correct because I
haven't read it I'm not sure it's 5,000
a day but it's not my problem not to
know that right I didn't read the bill
Molly I don't know how anyone could and
yet these jackasses put it out there and
then they say it must be passed
immediately and it's on you it's on you
for not reading it and I that just
pisses me off because to Tom's point you
know I'm not playing that game I'm not
going to like ingest this bloated
monstrosity because I don't trust you at
all anyway what do you say I just like
babbled they negotiated this bill in
secret for months they wouldn't let
anyone know what was going on then they
release it under dark of night and they
say you have to pass it immediately the
problem was Senator McConnell and
Senator Schumer what they really want is
funding for Ukraine and they said that
we'll pretend to care about the Border
if you give us what we really want and
the most of the money in this bill in
fact goes to Ukraine right but they
forgot that they were supposed to at
least pretend to care about border
security and instead it is it just Cod
all these things that were they're
already against the law so they're
actually expanding what is possible in
terms of breaking our laws to cross into
the country and it is a joke I mean I've
been in politics for a long time I have
seen a lot I have never seen anything as
offensive as what they're trying to do
with this sham border Bill
wow that's a high bar I've seen a lot of
offensive things I just saw something in
the Senate the other week oh my God yeah
by the way they never caught you rob you
know weirdly they did catch me yeah uh
and thank you for posting the video by
the way hey congratulations on your Fox
Nation special thank you it's uh it's
called uh it's called a history of the
world in six glasses Stars some very
very funny people hosted by Jim blushi
and D the Great Dan akroy lots of fun
Fox Nation just all you got to do is
sign up for Fox Nation for the rest of
your life and you can watch it so um I
also enjoy the holiday hobo look that
you're doing thank you well I I could I
grew it because I was preoccupied
reading the bill which I've
read doesn't it bother you how this
process works well but here's what two
things bother me one thing bothers me is
the bill itself I that you're going to
let 5,000 people in and that is going to
trigger the trouble but 5,000 is fine so
that means that everything in the border
is so messed up that there are people
who think well 5,000 is about as good as
we're going to get like that that's
considered a win for people who which is
bananas right so Americans are thinking
well 5,000 seems like a lot like
actually it's not a lot it's like it's
it's is 50,000 so you're welcome yeah
exactly the second thing is like what if
you're a family in New York City and
you're kind of like struggling a little
what you should do is you should go to
Mexico sneak in the Border come back to
New York where they'll put you up in a
hotel and give you money right why would
you not do that why would exact why
would why would you know families a
little bit who are struggling
financially that's your that's your
holiday vacation right there kids we're
going to go to Mexico and then we're
going to come back we're going to stay
in a hotel in Time Square yeah right the
number one tourist attraction in the
world and we're g to and we're going to
get a free little gift card every
whatever every week from the mayor ex
like it's kind of great I don't know why
more Americans aren't doing that you
know right because you know why we're
Americans Rob and we don't game this
system right well oh I don't know Slow
Down slow down tiger yeah we do we don't
ride the rails like you do well we don't
ride the rails right we're makeing
little marks nice lady makes pies you
know like that hobo marks uh no we do do
all that but we're we're that's because
we're Americans and that's that's the
privilege of being an American you like
if you're not an American you look you
can either have a generous welfare state
or you can have open borders can't have
boat that is true cat has said that many
times C and I would quote you on it but
why bother cuz you're right
you're right here you know what it feels
like it does feel like two things one we
are watching votes on reparations but
we're just this is a reparation for
people who don't even live here right
and number two what Rob's talking about
is gaming the system anytime the
Democrats create something they never
think about how a system can be gained
well incentives govern everything right
so if there's an incentive to come here
why wouldn't people come here uh and to
protect prend like that doesn't exist is
just absolutely absurd I mean you're if
you can say okay don't come here but if
you do we're going to give you money and
a place to stay then that's your the
first part doesn't matter it's like do
you ever have a friend who's always
going on and on and on to you like H my
ex won't leave me alone like he's
texting me all the time you won't leave
me alone oh my God he's so annoying but
she leaves out the fact that every time
she gets drunk she's sleeping with him
MH there's incentives for him to do it
so what she's saying doesn't matter yeah
that's a great uh a great analogy the
thing is you know uh we talk about
incentives but the disincentives aren't
there meaning that if you just send
somebody back that's just like playing a
game of pinball you just play another
game so they come back and they come
back over again you send it back they
you need to put them in a worse position
than they were if they hadn't broken the
law so maybe we do send them to
Anchorage you know you or you know what
I mean or and then you and then you
punish also the the Das you send the
felons to their block I mean you have to
create a distance incentive for Behavior
I think the people who are most
surprised by this are probably the
migrants if you explain to them what's
happening they must think themselves
wait a minute this is too good this is
am I being punked here yeah exact this
can't be true right you're me free stuff
no this can't be true because the
countries they come from don't offer any
of those yeah exactly well said hobo man
thank you up next Nikki Haley in a
sketch is guaranteed to make you
wretch if you'll be in the New York area
and would like tickets to see gutf go to
foxnews.com
jutfelt and click on the link to join
our studio
audience hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else